also says he thinks we'll be back flying
by June and defense his company's slow
processing of refunds in his first
broadcast interview since the crisis
began the daughter under scan did the
scale of the challenge currently being
faced by Airlines and refunds in a
normal month we process about 10,000
refunds for occasional flight
cancellations things like that were
staffed up for that at the moment we're
working with about a quarter of that
normal refund staff because of social
distancing and bans on people traveling
to work but we're dealing just in the
month of April with 10 million refunds
because all of the flights have been
canceled so we have 25 percent of the
staff dealing with about 10,000 times
the normal level of refunds now we are
processing refunds but what we try to
explain to everybody is it's going to
take us weeks and months to get around
to everybody but we will get to you
eventually if what you want is a cash
refund the French government allows tour
operators up to 18 months to pay a
refund airlines don't have that sort of
leeway would you like to see that being
introduced as an expedient I don't think
it makes any difference you know because
whether it's 18 months or not we will
still get to you I think certainly
within the 18 month period but what
we're asking most people to do just to
help us ease the backlog is no huge
numbers need to fly with Ryanair fly
with us regularly just move your booking
to July August September when at least
we know we will be back flying with some
kind of risk restrictions but if you
want a cash refund that's fine but as
we've explained but the cash refund is
going to take us many months to get
round to and we're getting around to it
in sequence even once our people are
allowed to come back to work here in
head office we would have to spool up
and add many more people to process
refunds now you said this week that if
the government allows you to start
flying again but has to insist on the
middle seat being kept empty you're not
gonna start flying me again why is that
well there's two things one the middle
seat and May you know delivers nothing
in terms of social distancing there'll
be no social distancing boarding an
aircraft off but getting off an aircraft
even if you kept the middle seat free
that is less than two and a half feet of
space compared to the sole
traditional grammars two liters and the
peat the person sitting behind you and
in front of you in the is seat or in the
window seat is toast attuned and even at
two and a half feet so social distancing
in an airline tube is as implementable
and it is on the underground and on
trains but what we're saying to
government is if you want to impose that
non effective social distancing measure
you pay for the middle seek the airlines
aren't around Europe generally operate
with a profit margin of about four or
five percent with a load factor of
eighty five percent and if you mandate
and tell us we can only operate with a
sixty percent load factor then frankly
we will all lose money we won't fly what
are the implications for the business
and for jobs if that scenario doesn't
unfold us you're expecting then honestly
we don't know we just have to keep
watching it I mean like what we try to
do is we've kept everybody or almost
everybody in employment at the moment
now with the benefits thankfully of the
the various payroll and support schemes
in the UK and Ireland and Spain and
Italy so we're keeping almost all of our
pilots and cabin crew in employment and
that support we're topping it up and
where we can and so we are ready to come
back pretty quickly but you know if that
situation changes we've certainly
guaranteed to all of our people that so
we will maintain the payroll through
April and through May if it continues
beyond that I think we will have to look
at some job losses because it's also we
get to the winter schedule any closer we
will be that there will be some job
losses but we're doing everything in our
power to keep people on the payroll of
Tanzer have applied for ten billion
euros of state aid from the German
government Virgin Atlantic has asked the
UK government for financial support
should they get it no I mean you know
like Lufthansa is like is it's like a
crack cocaine junkie looking for stage
aid getting huge payroll supports sales
support from the German government what
you need more state aid for like
actually we don't have many other costs
at the moment because we're all grounded
but if you get a state payroll support
as we and IAG in other air and said what
do you need the ten billion for and by
the way it's not just ten billion they
look for ten billion for the German
government
for nearly opinion from the Austrian
government from the Swiss government I
mean it's just they are off their heads
they see this I think is an opportunity
to get one last huge quantity of state
aid so they can go around and buy up
everybody when this is all over Virgin
Atlantic is ridiculous you know you've
an airline but this is Branson's second
goal was trying to fleece the British
taxpayer for stage age you know he tried
to with fly B which was owned by Delta
himself and it and a New York VC company
now you have Virgin Atlantic owned by
Delta and a Caribbean island based
non-resident billionaire frankly if he's
worried about Virgin he should write to
check himself it's not like he's short
of money you know his Virgin Galactic
investment is worth about 1.3 billion
today so sitting in the Virgin Islands
as a tax a tax exile asking the British
government to bail you out when you have
more than sufficient resources to bail
out Virgin Atlantic yourself is not
something I believe that should be
considered I think it's inevitable when
we do go back to flying and I think late
June early July is a reasonable date at
the moment I think both our pastors and
our staff will all be wearing masks or
face coverings I think we will be doing
temperature controls on all passengers
and staff at the airports not unlike
what they're doing in Asia at the moment
and if you look at the experience in
China they're back up to about 70
percent of their pre covert flight
programs with load factors of about 50
to 60 percent so you know the world will
recover reasonably quickly
I think flying will recover faster
because we will all be discounting
prices and hotels will be discounting
prices but you know it will flying will
be somewhat different in that right
we'll all be wearing face masks for a
month you know a certainty at the end of
the year